hey what's good is your boy j.i.d and
check me out on the bootleg care podcast
[Music]
yo it's the bootleg cab show we got a
special guest in here i'm gonna say it
because all of the amazing rappers that
i know that i talked about who's that
[ __ ] you know rappers got their
favorite rappers one of the illest
[ __ ] alive j.i.d is here
welcome man what's good bro um first of
all i've been very appreciative of the
lucy's you've been dropping obviously
the spillage village project was
incredible yeah um
why has it taken so long to drop a new
body of work from you
uh
four years right four years in some
change fakely like
it's i would say three you know what i'm
saying because i dropped november like
2018. yeah so about three yeah and then
that whole year we toured like the whole
2019.
and then um
2020 came did the grammys because it
spilled because of the
revenge project came out 2019.
obviously you got the grammy now grammy
noms
and then um 2020
we were supposed to go to japan i
suppose as opposed to going to tour in
tokyo whatever and then kobe hit
and that's when i really started working
on the album you know what i'm saying
about my recognizance you know what i'm
saying i started working on it so you
started like 20. like your process has
been like a two-year process kind of
yeah yeah
and i've been dropping so much work
since the conway record is crazy yeah
that's my dog that is hard you got one
of them ones from him too yeah yeah yeah
yeah so
yeah i don't see it like that you know
what i'm saying the the circumstances of
the world
i'm sure it would have came out in 2020
without minus uh
the the state of the world of course
talk about your relationship with with
conway obviously uh you hopped on
scatterbrain which is close to going
gold uh it is yeah i just talked to him
uh earlier last week i think he's gonna
go gold soon yeah um did you go i know
he did that on tv did you were you on tv
with him when he did that yeah we did it
on um i believe it was falling when you
see someone like conway or just in
general like uh mc that you feel like
is
you know one of them once like
do you feel like kind of like you know
as like almost like a jedi relationship
with like certain rappers where you kind
of gotta like reach out and be like yo i
see what you're doing yeah 100
we i feel like we tapped in and maybe
2018
just on some like mutual respect i feel
like it was around the time i did like
the funk flex freestyle yeah and
ever since i feel like we've been tapped
in um
super solid dude but the all them guys
over there you know what i'm saying sure
west side like
um i'm body all them they're amazing i
love them all these incredible i love
all of them so um
i feel like makami too is he with them
yeah my commies with that crazy you know
what i'm saying streets there's a lot of
yeah crazy
stove got cooks
caesar yeah they got a dope camp over
there i just respect it i like movements
like that when it's like super based in
like the uh
the pure form of like hip-hop i would
say you know what i'm saying one of my
favorite uh new artists
relatively new i mean he's been doing
his thing um but i love kenny man and
you got kenny on this uh this drop that
just this came out obviously he's
somebody from from atl yeah somebody who
i think somehow is a little
underappreciated you know um but is i
feel like you're going to have a crazy
career ahead of them um just talk about
like linking up with kenny man and just
kind of
you know shine some light on on him in
general because i feel like he's he's
one of them ones as well yeah brushy's
dope um
real i'm just like a super
fan of like atlanta you know what i'm
saying just just what that whole scene
brings so i'm like super supportive or
whatever even if some people may hate it
or whatever like i'm just super
supportive of the sounds that's coming
from the city so there's a lot of uh
up-and-coming artists that i like and i
show love to you know what i'm saying
just because
it needs that light being shined you
know what i'm saying i got
blessed with the opportunity with
somebody like shining light on me yeah
got me to this point where i'm talking
to you you know what i'm saying so
i just trying to do my part it ain't
even too much thought into it you know
what i'm saying if you're talented like
you from the city like i'm doing this
it's black and white for real give me
some of the background um
obviously spillage village is uh a crew
before you guys were
everyone was signed yeah you know what
i'm saying you
give me the dynamics because where it
was at a house everybody was living in
uh was it shout out to marieba shout out
to black shout out to everybody who's
involved
give me kind of like the breakdown of of
like the the roots of spillage village
because it's like almost like y'all are
like low-key like
very reminiscent of the dungeon family
coming out of the a you know what i mean
um it started with me earth king we
literally said hey we should be a
collective you know what i'm saying we
was going to school at the same time
in virginia so
we're able to do but cook for
sure that was amazing i love that
reference shout out to um shout out to
the clip did you push like that or
who said that that's a mallet that's
malice on the hook yeah that's malice
where did you guys he's amazing
um but yeah we was all up in through
virginia but i got kicked out of school
so like trying to figure out what's next
let's start this collective like things
really was already rapping together
fakely in the dorms like trying to
figure out
how to put it together but then we said
let's put it together me and earth game
so we started it and then we had the
homies like hollywood jb and jordan
bryant like
they brothers they were just amazing and
then maribya and black was just like we
knew them from the city
did shows around the same type of little
scene we had and then it just all worked
out it was really family you know what
i'm saying we all live in the same house
at a time period we're just sleeping on
couches and stuff like that not marie
but more so cause you know i'm saying
[ __ ] lady but all the boys who used to
love it you know what i'm saying college
dorm room style right now
what's what's like what's that crib like
with you earth gang black everybody in
the crib yeah is it like everyone's
always recording is it like what's like
what is that like yeah it wasn't like
you know what i'm saying we was moving
around we wasn't just sitting in the
house recording so some days like
somebody be on the mic like me i wake up
every morning got right to it before
anybody i'm up six in the morning with
it but everybody's moving around doing
different things and we just tried to
find time to make music together and
then like separately we had to make our
projects to get us
the individual like you know what i'm
saying so
it was
it was kind of organized it was kind of
mature as hell because i knew what he
was going for nah and it worked out i
feel like it i feel like there's not
enough uh
i feel like people don't know that story
enough because if you think about
everybody's really doing their thing
everybody signed everybody like
contour on their own was black like the
first guy that really kind of popped off
yeah black killed it free black was
[ __ ] classic [ __ ] insane bro um
and i just saw it in him like i saw the
trajectory of where he was gonna go just
off his work ethic and just how he used
to move around like do you have any
intel on when he's gonna put out a new
album because it's been a while
that's right
no i ain't got too much deep man
i'll be on it though i'm gonna be on it
i'll tell you that i tell you this the
lvrn guys have come through here with
like three artists in the last two
months and every time they come i'm like
guys
what's up
what is going on with the black [ __ ] we
need a new i i feel like the last album
was
2019 was it 2018 it might be 18.
yeah i might be 18.
it feels like it feels like a while at
least
yeah you got to be i think it's 18. um
you obviously are
very distinct you're very unique in your
delivery i feel like uh in a world in
which we have so many artists that sound
alike or at least very you know
influenced by each other i feel like
you're kind of quite the opposite
um who would you say you grab
inspiration from whether it's old heads
or you know uh [ __ ] you grown up growing
up listening to or new [ __ ]
um
it really like bounced around like my
number one inspiration
in music from when it came to me like at
a time when i needed it was like a group
called little dragon little dragon from
gothenburg sweden bros like my favorite
group in the world
world yeah like i was going through
something crazy and i found the music
and it
helped me even become a better writer
better is the music in english or is it
in english and it's super soulful you
know what i'm saying it's pop funky it's
not like rap [ __ ] but it's
grey sounds and and then of course like
all the the mega hip-hop
people we know of course jay-z like lil
wayne like these are my like
i'm curious who's who's on you're like
mount rushmore
like give me your five like no no order
you don't got to give me the order
because that's where things get kind of
hairy when you're like jersey wayne okay
okay it says one mm-hmm little dragon
and
sliding the family stone or d'angelo
like they're super okay we're talking
about mc's here oh we got to talk about
rap yeah we're trying to rap okay
straight rap
so jay-z wayne
outcast is one
um
now it gets tricky right it does get
tricky yeah wayne hove outcast so far
you're three for three a little swisher
earl sweatshirt it's kind of crazy right
wow
um
it's tough i don't even know yeah one
more i know you gotta feel it think like
a lot of names
look at the names on the wall like
what are some names going through your
head like thug like
like uh k-dot of course
yeah um
like there's so many people that i just
like love so much yeah you have you have
you seen bay aka or formerly known as
most def on the project kind of crazy
that's crazy you hear that first i have
not i have not yet
but let me tell you something
i just had a um
con mate me and conway were riding
around in denver last week and we're
listening to respiration by black star
and we're going back and forth about
childhood quality versus most and i was
like
i love tyler that's my guy i'm like i
don't even think it's just discussion i
think most definitely like
if most def like applied himself in
hip-hop he'd be like
[ __ ] man you got to think like black we
got black on both sides in black star
and then what was the name of the album
that came out like a few years later
where he had the [ __ ] over his face i
had sunshine on there but i feel like he
always was one foot in one foot out with
the rap [ __ ] for real like imagine if he
really was like dug in it would have
been crazy yeah
it would have been cool i heard
chappelle say like even the way he moved
is just like super brilliant too i think
because i heard chappelle say something
like artists
don't you shouldn't want to be a
commodity you know what i'm saying
you get you know what i'm saying yeah
i feel like that's like kind of a
powerful ass statement to accept you
know what i'm saying commodities are
like water
like right all the [ __ ] that you need
but it's just like no you don't want to
be seen as that you want to be seen as
like 101 or you want to be seen as a
fingerprint snowflake or some [ __ ]
no it's kind of deep to me so i think
you're doing a pretty good job of that
yeah yeah for sure yeah um
my favorite artists
are consistent but it's more so in their
product
you know what i'm saying they're not
always in your face but when they come
they come up with that it matters that's
what that's that's what i love about it
yeah i love artists that drop a lot of
consistency as well like a lot of trap
artists like stay on it like that's
their bag and that shit's beautiful i
love it you know what i'm saying but
it's just different ways to skin a cat
who the [ __ ] says
where does skinny cat come from that's
kind of crazy to say i've never skinned
a cat yeah skinny cat do you know anyone
who's skinned a cat oh i think it'll be
a hard [ __ ] task too i
my cats are crazy you know
[ __ ] you
what yeah i always say i'll [ __ ] i'll
take a fight with a dog over a [ __ ]
tomcat it depends oh it depends on the
type of dog though cause dogs get busy
okay like a golden lab
give me the golden uh airbud you wanna
fight airbus i fought air i'll fight
airball airbud over [ __ ] jerry bro
where's it tom tom
dude cats are [ __ ] they're quick
they're ninjas and they got the claws
bruh i um
i named my cat frank ocean do you have a
cat
would you consider yourself a cat person
i hate his ass
but we just got like a mufasa thing it's
like two lions like but he be
doing [ __ ] like this is my
my shorty cat so okay they're gonna be
yeah get on the tallest part of the
whatever yeah they collaboratively just
stand there like you just at the top of
pride rock like he's overlooking the
peasants yeah like this is my show just
so y'all know this is my [ __ ]
[ __ ] like that so okay different but the
cat's name is frank ocean yeah do you
have a dog as well
had a dog
um
passed away oh that's rough man i'm a
huge dog turtle named turtle
well turtles live
they're supposed to live kinda
so this is
we went to a fair or some [ __ ] and got a
small little turtles you know the one
they give it that's kind of corner main
too yes oh yeah you got it anywhere
you're going and they're selling animals
on the side of the street they're just
giving these [ __ ] out it's like on
auburn they're like we can't get these
off these joints are sick take the
turtle gave us this one turtle
we keep the turtle for a couple of weeks
feeding them and all of this stuff but i
start doing research and they say these
turtles need a companion or they will
just off themselves so in the next
couple of weeks [ __ ] stop eating
he started making a little turtle noise
and then he started putting his head
under the you know you got the little
gravel at the bottom of the tank this
[ __ ] was in pure loneliness like he
committed suicide it was the saddest i
seen turtle suicide it was the saddest
[ __ ] i've ever seen in my life i'm
talking about in the span of like three
days four days he was just like i'm done
he just killed himself he's like i'm not
eating so where's my girl where's my
where's anything i just need to knock
around some stuff side note if the cat's
frank ocean who's the turtle his name
was turtle the just turtle yeah i
respect that i don't feel like i don't
feel like yeah amphibian right
are turtles amphibians am i right
what the [ __ ] is it it's a what
a reptile what the [ __ ] is an amphibian
in a lizard a frog is an amphibian okay
okay turtles reptiles
they don't hear i don't feel like they i
feel like they only see like heat when i
was a kid i had a
box turtle and i named him fat joe
that's hard
i'd be knowing my [ __ ] you know
hey we got to stop the interview real
quick to tell you about our partners our
family at odd socks go to
oddssoxofficial.com right now
and the promo code bootleg kev it'll get
you 20 off the fly of socks in the world
[ __ ] spongebob
[ __ ] cheez-its
a little bit of pepsi
uh how about how about some underwear do
we like underwear e.t boxers let's go
ahead and just open up a pair of these
boys so you can see how fly the draws
are ladies and gentlemen because they
are fly by the way they just gave me my
own pair of odd socks go on my social
media and you could see them uh i don't
know if they're going to be for sale
because let's be honest
who wants to wear socks with my [ __ ]
ugly face on them besides my wife and
she don't even want to wear them there
we go
they got the draws they got it all man
get the odd socks basics which i love
just the basic boys these are amazing
comfy socks
oddssocksofficial.com use the promo code
bootleg kev save 20 off let's get back
to the interview yeah
so you know
how um how old was your dog when your
dog passed away
i actually don't know it was crazy we
was trying to find like
this is a crazy story this is maybe like
three four years ago we was trying to
get a bull mastiff mm-hmm got on uh
craigslist
got the dog for like
60 bucks said it was a bull mastiff
wasn't it [ __ ] was
anything but a bull master it could have
been mixed with cat for us i know but he
uh i don't know how old he was 60 bucks
for a bull mastiff feels like a little
low you just rough time do you know what
i'm saying you're like you know what
yeah i trust this guy sixty dollars even
though it's probably like a two thousand
dollar dog that's a huge two thousand
dollar dog it was supposed to be way
bigger it just had big paws you know how
they saying big paws especially if it's
a puppy they'll be like look at his paws
it's gonna go up to be huge that dog was
not it he was not him but he lived for
maybe
i don't know he ran away and then never
seen him again so i just he might still
be out here man he might be out here
doing his thing that's great running it
up
yo uh
when when it comes to your album uh i
saw the artwork uh the artwork is crazy
uh give me kind of like the whole
concept but behind the title and the
artwork
um
so this project is uh it's a sequel i
love doing sequels because i like movies
and [ __ ] so i feel like if it's a good
first movie like i want to see the
second one okay it's always like that so
i've been doing it my whole career just
making them in sequels this was like
if you look at the first cover it was
animated drawn out a bunch of chaos
almost wears water but you see a lot of
like trauma black issues and stuff like
that cops football players basketball
players people in jail and then we
decided to bring
this cover to live action to like to
real life
so we got even like some of the family
members that represented some of these
places some of my sisters some of my
brothers my cousins my friends
and
and then just other people who just
could feel those roles and we brought it
to life and it's just kind of showing
like
even if you see like where i'm placed at
in the first one i'm kind of like on the
outside but i'm still close to the
center and this one i'm like dead in the
middle
it's kind of like representing like
where i see myself at this point in my
life you know what i'm saying yeah i
left
did all the touring and stuff made a
success of myself whatever my mom would
say
and um
when i come back it's kind of like i see
the same things you know what i'm saying
this is kind of like a representation of
my mindset
yeah i think uh chaos i think
i feel like artwork nowadays is like
very um
my i just feel like people don't put
enough thought into their [ __ ] well so
when i see like your [ __ ] i'm like damn
this this is crazy or so shout out to
you even like like a guy like west side
boogie his artwork is was crazy on his
album crazy album too by the way shout
out to boogie um baby tate's on the
project
she's fired i just met her in miami
she's amazing shout out to her she had
uh
i asked her who was uh her all-time trap
artist and she did not include jeezy
geezy or ti crazy i was a little i was a
little old
dang she said scooter fire
she really atlanta girl yeah no scooter
is [ __ ] incredible
gucci obviously of course what the
amigos what
and
say ole miss i'll say you owe me a verse
i don't know why i can't think of the
guy's name make the trap say eh
we signed a gucci duma juice man oj the
juice man
where would you put like you were if you
had we're talking about trap trap music
atlanta
hmm
i mean
of course like
t.i got it shout out
it's t-i-g-z
yeah yeah in that order
in that order just because t.i trap
music that's a staple who's got more
classics
but i'm not doing it i'm not answering
it it's cheesy
i think it's cheesy
i think you got you got i'm playing the
fifth all right all right only because
random question would you take uh
tm 101 or the recession
didn't want easy
but the recession recession was amazing
it was good but i'm taking tn101 it just
reminded me of a time period in atlanta
100 a whole new wall party like just
some young [ __ ] all right so we got to
fill it out well you said uh
ti cheesy
still got guys out there like gucci
i don't go the little baby up there
already it's hard let's go baby
baby man oh god
i've never seen somebody improve so
drastically at rapping so fast
don't you agree like
he's nudity was my last one oh nudie
yeah shout out to nudie
nudie's also someone who doesn't get
enough flowers nationally at least yeah
um
little baby though yeah you're a [ __ ]
mc's mc yeah hasn't it been crazy to see
just how impeccable he's gotten like at
this rapping [ __ ] no just what he's made
for it's so it's so impressive
you could tell when he said somebody you
know what i'm saying you could tell this
was his calling because he went from
like being like really open like yeah
gunna like helps me like help me start
to write and [ __ ] and like now he's like
top tier
don't miss yeah he deserves it though he
did yeah he deserves it i don't really
like gifted so
you said officers reverse anybody else
will be a version
no that's my dog i'm just [ __ ] with
you um no no no no no
uh is there i mean this is the uh
quintessential is there gonna be another
dreamville compilation question
that'll be smart yeah you know what i'm
saying that'll be smart to do that the
last one was so epic and if we brought
it in hone it anymore just about make it
more so about the uh the collective you
know what i'm saying because there's a
lot of outside yeah we just a couple
features here in there just make it
about the collective it'll be way it was
so good though man it was really good
i told the e but i was like bro the fact
that you because i know that y'all
pulled from he pulled from so many
records
and i was like bro the fact you're able
to pull from so many different joints
and make like i'm sure a scattered
creative process sounds so cohesive yeah
so many different artists shout out to
eve did his name good guy for short man
on album rapping
he was on the album rapping what yeah
don't forget i said that just listen for
he sound like mf doom on god
you got ibrahim rapping
is boss on the song too
you doing like uh you got boss on the
album right yeah you don't like
backgrounds and you know what i'm saying
yeah i love boss now that he's like kind
of in his like melodic bag that's why
yeah like he killed the coal album facts
facts i love his parts on there yeah
when i was like i was like who the [ __ ]
is this i said she said
i'm like you got a new pocket what yeah
boss amazing you uh correct me if i'm
wrong you were on like a kind of like a
pop tour or is that
oh i was uh going around doing shows at
imagine dragons imagine dragons yeah
what was that like i'm a pop star bro
no i'm just saying because an imagine
dragon's concert is like a whole
different world what's a serial like a
serious level of caucasian that goes to
those shows 100 you know what i mean and
i'm definitely like
the the minority in the biggest regard
you know what i'm saying so
i [ __ ] with it though they got some
anthems yeah like they literally have
stadium music 100 you heard that [ __ ] in
target you heard it in commercials and
commercials everywhere in the movies and
soundtracks all of that stuff um it's
crazy bro it's just a whole nother level
of performing it teaches you like i'm
gonna say that has to really like you
gotta cut your teeth going into a crowd
that's probably not there for what
you're bringing to the table arenas
uh but our song is one of their biggest
songs ever you know what i'm saying is
probably i think it was the fastest to
reach
the heights that are you know i'm saying
i don't know to the heights of me but
that song big as hell so they know who i
am like every time i perform they just
roaring applause it's crazy like just
making sure like even the way i'm
rapping i'm rapping super fast so it's
just like me doing 26 seconds of like
i'm out of there but yeah i don't know
it helped me become a better performer i
would say who reached out was it someone
in the group that was just a fan of you
that was like like dan uh reynolds
uh he's a
lead singer i feel like he was a fan he
he told me that he was and it was done
through the label the labor response i
think it was because of you [ __ ] with me
when people chop and they do the
i feel like
um sometimes it's amazing sometimes
there's guys like ritz from
gwinnett county who could rap really
fast and say incredible things yeah um
tech9 is really good at that yeah but
then sometimes it's like
unbearable it's it's like really
unbearable you know what i actually
i'm just like this
i hate i hate it though like this is who
i am i can't see listen to that she
thought i wouldn't would you would you
listen to your own album yes okay
because my [ __ ] is fire yes it's some
[ __ ] [ __ ]
can't comment on that
no idea what you're talking about
but
and i'll respect it and all but i
it's kind of crazy i don't be like
really delving into it if i know this is
your niche i don't think it's my niche i
think i could just do it i just do it
like you know what i'm saying
effortlessly effortless i'm not trying
to rap like this my name is
jittery for a reason because i'm just
like my brain like but
i don't really
aim for that style of music right you or
i wouldn't even say rap is the first
thing i would press play on in my car
yeah i feel like eminem for being like
one of the greatest rappers of all time
i don't like when he raps like that it's
not for me but shout out to him
curtin call two out now
oh god did you listen to eminem growing
up
i i i used to love stan still listen to
he's a great first three hours i saw
like first three albums are great yeah
yeah all of the craziness yes that's the
g unit [ __ ] that whole era but i was i
wasn't like
super am i like
wait it was eminem like super prominent
two thousand [ __ ] two until yeah i
mean no no
technically
like 99. something 98.99 until poison at
this time i'm really like at this age
i'm really like catching up on i'm in a
new orleans sound i'm really [ __ ] 400
degrees all of that
hey listen let me tell you something you
know one of my favorite albums is of all
time i got that work by the big timers
wow that is that's crazy bro i still
underwrite it unspoken about you
understand that it wasn't on dsps until
like four months ago and now it's on
[ __ ] i don't know there's a lot of
old cash money [ __ ] that's just
in the air somewhere i'm looking for the
remember the song on tuesdays and
thursdays you gotta why i'm looking for
the album with that on it i cannot find
it it's like tuesdays and thursdays it's
like uh
like the manny fresh uh first solo
albums not available the birdman album
what happened to that boy
was that do you remember that artwork by
the way with the half oh my god it's
kind of crazy
it's so crazy to think that that was
like flying back then like
like those those like old school
southern covers with the but that was
that one was egregious the birdman album
cover was the greatest it was insane but
i used to love them old covers with like
the hot boys around oh amazing like the
silk the shocker charger to the game i
used to never be the biggest shocker
well he was a terrible rapper i
respected him because master p like this
is your brother so i'm giving him i
think silk the shocker is the best worst
rapper of all time
he or she platinum he's the worst worst
wrestler he went platinum before
streaming
so we can't even hit him with that and
he was and
he was uh
romantically involved with maya in about
in 98 so god bless him right absolutely
kudos shout out him and maya had some
joints shout out to seal yeah he was in
the video in the white jacket and you
know on the snow mm-hmm
slopes and [ __ ] was hard you know uh
early cash money was the best yeah [ __ ]
yeah that's what i was at big timers
though that's the album yeah get your
roll on man it's one of my favorite
songs of all time damn bro yeah [ __ ]
man that's i feel like they still play
that [ __ ] in like commercials right
i think so i love that [ __ ] um yeah so
uh this album
are we gonna have another drop-off in
terms of just bodies of work from you
because you feel very intentional when
you drop music see i've been working on
like a couple albums in this time period
so we're gonna spin a block again you're
going to spin the block yeah that's good
solo yeah
yeah what about well i was just like
spillage village coming out yeah yeah
yeah we definitely i've been trying to
like
get us pushed in that direction i think
we can get something we just got to find
everybody's schedule and get together
and do it a lot of moving parts a lot of
moving parts but i know it's uh
another album i know it's damn near a
tour like we need to tour off of these
these projects we've been dropping so
yeah y'all definitely got a tour
100 yeah yeah i mean i feel like
with you like uh you're like because
i've seen you live before yeah i feel
like the live aspect of what you bring
to the table is so important was it
frustrating like not being able to
perform hit the road
yeah yeah of course that was and that's
like most artists made like mainstream
of income it's just touring and
festivals and merch and
you know what i'm saying of course
you're gonna see you may see some
streaming money or whatever i guess um
you know how this should work but
i just know like most of the artists
touring is the income so that [ __ ]
probably hit people in different type of
ways it ain't [ __ ] me up too bad
because i toured the whole 2019 like we
did almost 300 shows in a year with 365
days
so you kind of got a little bit out of
your system i got it i got it out i did
my major tour in 2019 then 2020 was just
like when everything stopped in 2021
everything came back and now we're here
did you ever catch the covet
uh once once was it mild it was a mile
maybe a few days yeah coughs and sneeze
i wasn't that bad you know what's crazy
is like
monkey pock's not as deadly as covid but
but everyone's a lot more freaked out
because that [ __ ] looks crazy it looks
that's how you know how everybody is so
everyone's so vain
they're like i don't give a [ __ ] i just
don't want that on my face give me the
[ __ ] that could kill me i try to look
crazy that is i i didn't even peep that
but that is i can't even post on
instagram for how many months what
months no i mean i don't know i don't
know okay it just looks wild yeah like
you you low-key can't leave the house
you could leave the house with covid you
a piece of [ __ ] if you did it yeah
you're super spreader
but you could and no one would know
that monkey box you're at the [ __ ]
gym with monkey pox [ __ ] they'll
call the police on you bro you know
shoot down
jesus um
yo uh give me some insight man obviously
uh
being signed to dreamville
is the gift is uh amazing right because
i feel like they are a label that has
the highest uh
integrity when it comes to who they sign
i truly believe that i feel like cole
and eve when they sign somebody it is
never short-sighted it is always first
of all they develop artists um
and they always see the long play is the
downside every interview you do someone
asks you a j cole question by the way
only j cole question of the interview
no
no my name i don't care good guy good
cool dude yeah you ever played
basketball like y'all ever [ __ ] i
played yeah one of the toys we just shot
around like got a little game going to
the gym i feel like it was
in virginia kind of crazy yeah
gotta throw that in there got to play it
well um yeah i hooked around with him a
little bit
i ain't no really no football i didn't
really know basketball [ __ ] at all what
did what did you do we played football
with him before yeah you did you play
football in uh high school yeah high
school and college where where'd you
play in college and just school in
virginia where ain't none of the cook
yep
what's your team falcons
hmm how you feeling that's tough how you
feeling with mariota yesterday is it
mariota it's mariota and we got rid of
ritter um ritter
somebody drafted he just came in i feel
like he went to cincinnati they did
calvin really dirty or
or
i mean
what why what let me ask you why you
said it first
he gambled on a game that he had i mean
he shouldn't have gambled on the game
but he got suspended for a year a whole
year and deshawn watson's out here
getting habitual rub downs
and got six six games
does the nfl hate women
yo no say you can't say that
think about ray rice kareem hunt daisy
kareem hunt ezekiel elliott all those
[ __ ] played like uh
he would know ezekiel elliott's [ __ ] was
what
minimal
i got calvin ridley bet on a game
and it wasn't even i don't think it was
like a anything crazy
yeah a whole year bruh [ __ ] up my
fantasy [ __ ] bruh
oh that's your beef
let's get to it you put the root of it
do you play fantasy football i did it
the first time last year uh
i think i don't know if i'm a good gm i
would be a better coach i thought i'd be
good at it because i know personnel and
players and [ __ ] but that's more of
about like
it takes up a lot of time i couldn't do
it so i lost out of them what was the
draft like did you have an in-person
draft because because my favorite part
yes that's fun [ __ ] the best part about
fantasy football is when you get
together with your friends
and you just say just demeaning things
to them
cancible things even you know
while you're you know in the same room
you got the [ __ ] easel with the
[ __ ] thing and you're writing the
[ __ ] things down there's wings
there's beer
you know and then you know when someone
drafts like
i just love just just
putting down my best friends it's
actually my favorite thing to do when
they when they pick a bad pick or yeah
what the [ __ ] are you doing or some new
[ __ ] who picks like a kicker in
like the ninth round and i'm like bro
you know you could have just waited
until the end for that just giving them
[ __ ] the whole time why do you have
three defenses
like what's going on that's fine yeah it
does
yeah shout out to the fact i'm a
cardinals fan so she's hairy for us
right now because kylie murray seems to
be you know uh he got paid thank god
yeah hopefully now it's behind us
because they put the uh clause in his
contract where he has to study that's
racism
that's pure blatant racism
oh you know what
i love the nfl but
it's some moral things i can't even
really stand with that the black man
can't even really have to like deshawn
he he he's a different thing
but i think
i think that sean's just playing with
lamar all these black quarterbacks and
stuff like that like they trying to give
them little clauses and stuff like that
right right right that's
that's racism bro i think that um
deshawn watson is probably just a single
man i kind of don't even want to talk
about him well i'm just going to say
disgusting to me i don't even you know
he might just like a rubbing tug
he might just love to get the tug you
know what i mean hey
when uh what's the owner of the patriots
robert kraft robert kraft
they got photos of him leaving he got
too much money
i don't need meek mill coming for me
but robert kraft
no but listen robert kraft there's
[ __ ] pictures of him leaving the
rubbing tug
they couldn't they could they didn't
even suspend him let me tell you a funny
story
crazy story so uh at the grammys we sit
next to robert craft
uh we tell them we falcon's friend from
atlanta
brook taps he's
whatever he's holder
he pulled out the ring fed it to 283
diamonds on it because we lost 28 28 to
3.
oh well that was no no no you guys were
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah i got 283 diamonds yeah homie just
pulled it out
robert did that
that's back to this homie that's
wait wait wait so he was traveling
it wasn't even on his dick it was on
deck so he just had a guy holding the
super bowl rings i'll never forget it
bro imagine that's your gig yeah like yo
your job hundred thousand a year is i
give you six bands or six six figures
you just gotta carry the rings and when
some random piece of [ __ ] sports fan
comes up to me you crack this [ __ ] up
pull them boys out rob i called him rob
like you my boy rob looked at us he was
like this is the ring he closed the show
what up we gotta interrupt the interview
real quick to tell you about our people
at blue chew don't forget to go to
bluetooth.com
use the promo code bootleg right now and
get your first month free all you gotta
do is pay five dollars in shipping it's
the uh man fellas the game changer
that's all i'ma say
you pop the blue chew and your dick is
on a million
man i'm not saying it makes it bigger
but it feels bigger i'm just saying i'm
not saying but i'm saying uh look same
active ingredient asialis and viagra
minus the awkward visits to the doctor's
office all right it's all over the phone
it's so easy they ship it right to your
door in discreet packaging
uh i don't know if you're going through
erectile dysfunction because you're
stressed out at work uh maybe uh you
just need a little extra hump with wifey
whatever it is maybe you just want to
take a bluetooth and beat your dick like
it stole something just to feel like
damn that shit's hard bruh you know what
i'm saying go to bluetooth.com use the
promo code bootleg right now and you
will save uh all money it's free yeah
you'll you'll get a whole month for free
bluechew.com promo code bootleg for a
whole month for free delivered to your
door discreetly no doctor's appointments
no awkward visits same viagra cialis
ingredients
man what are you waiting for go do that
speaking of rings you have a cat named
frank ocean did you see frank ocean's
luxurious [ __ ] ring that he released
that's amazing
i love uh black progress did you see it
at his progression did you see this
thing it's twenty five thousand dollars
i didn't see it but i mean i didn't see
i didn't i mean i don't think she's
crazy it looks like a very nice men's
engagement ring my dog zach fox posted
it on his page and said he knows he's
hilarious he's crazy he's so funny yeah
yeah yeah i know i know what you're
talking about yeah we love frank though
we need frank to drop music yeah yeah
he's another one of them he's you know
what i'm saying like you said that's
what you were talking about earlier not
a commodity not here to be your
commodity bro 100 he's gonna do what he
wants when he wants to do it when it
feels good and it feels good
the [ __ ] ring is outside that [ __ ] is
amazing
my nigga's in 2050 right now he said 20
can you imagine if you're the guy that
spends 25 000 on that like imagine how
rich you gotta be to be like it cost
twenty five thousand twenty five
thousand dollars
no don't get one that's weird why not a
[ __ ] ring i feel like it's a weird lady
you just going on with it right quick
[Music]
i'm not sure i'm not sure uh it's being
marketed for the uh you know for the uh
guys with the stuff right yeah yeah
let's stop stop yeah listen the album uh
the album is out right now um you have a
crazy
obviously the the the features on this
little wayne 21 savage
james blake
[ __ ] wild yeah
uh
also
[ __ ] huge in the caucasian world the
mountains of caucasia they love james
break amazing um baby tate's on the
project
um boss you got the ceo rapping
someone hits play on this what's the
first song like let's say i can only
listen to one song
what would be your your choice like yo
you got to go this is the one record on
here that you should go straight to if
you can only listen to one
uh brother name it's called brother now
okay featuring dirt
okay yeah it's crazy fire yeah we got
dirk and like uh you know how you know
what i'm saying we gotta brought them to
my world you got dirk like
really
it ain't like
it's just it's my world you know what
i'm saying so it could be a bunch of
different things it could be melodic it
could be like some rap [ __ ] yeah be like
some turn [ __ ] but i just did something
i think a lot of people would expect and
he went so crazy bro like
spoke about [ __ ] you know i'm saying
personal [ __ ] and it just kind of moved
me i'm like oh you really like the voice
that's what really everything you say
awesome that's what they say 100
uh before you get out of here can you
shout out any up-and-coming mc's that
you're just a fan of that you really
feel like are
maybe flying under the radar a bit you
want to shed some light on oh
let me see okay from atlanta i'm gonna
say my dog marco plus
um
i don't know if it's still upcoming but
i think flo millie is like amazing she's
crazy and she's on the new race
remembered single he had um community
community deck right yeah
he had to finish it
i left it up there
it's not community college
can you imagine if rachel remembered
obviously imagine if a race remembered
at a record called community college i
would love to hear with that i've i've
streamed that [ __ ] right away funny
thing funny thing uh i was listening to
black beatles this [ __ ] popped in my
head i was listening the other day
classic didn't age so well in the club
classic my twin my twins say uh
frat girl still trying to i said frat
girls
frat fraternity
he's supposed to say sorority but that's
just a little inside i just thought
about it but that's my dog
so they could do a community college
thing because they could i don't know
the [ __ ] whole bread is like college
fun community good uh good uh good
sitcom by the way chevy chase yeah [ __ ]
with it
with donald glover
um last question
you said you're big on movies yeah
you're uh
very much in tune with the with with
movies acting etc
give me your
three movies if you're on an island you
can only take three movies with you what
are the what are the flicks we're taking
man
um
all right
so we're gonna go
roots
okay no roots of course you know what
i'm talking about yes there's like so
many of them
that's a crazy choice crazy choice to
take on an island
for sure watching just be mad all day
yeah it's roots
um i'm down with that because if i'm on
the island i'd rather be mad
right yeah because it'll motivate you to
get off the island okay fair enough yeah
so we go roots
you know t.i was in the roots they
upgraded the movie the movie came out of
like 1967. you know t.i was in one that
came out in like 2011 or something right
about the same he was a slave
it's kind of crazy but he was talking
like tia of today
you gotta see it you gotta see it it was
amazing so he was hitting like what the
ill the ill t.i is just killing that
[ __ ] but
on slave clothes it was outside outside
but i would bring roots and i would try
to bring that version too because tia is
crazy i didn't even know there was this
version that's like you know did you
know there's a belly too yeah with the
game terrible movie i watch horrible
movies and great movies all the time
belly belly posters up above you it's
the best worst movie ever
it's such a great movie i don't know if
i agree with that it's so many epic
movie epic parts in that movie that's
classic in our culture that no but
storyline no no i agree story like as a
kid is like my favorite [ __ ] movie
but i grow up and i'm like every time i
re-watch belly i'm like god damn this
story line was terrible
boy listen that [ __ ]
the dude in nebraska eating a banana
that's what i fit did that
that's what popped off dmx career is
acting right was this before no no no
dmx
was already him he was already him okay
he already had two number one albums
i'm talking about as far as acting
though was he acting before this was
this one as his first it might have
rose that got him into romeo must die
exit
i think that what it didn't do was kick
off nasa's acting career because he was
god awful in it that's sincere
yeah it's like yo
you just gotta get out of here he was
talking to the little nick on the beach
oh my god
we just gotta make it
i want to go to africa
my god
t.i was or naz was uh it was not the uh
crazy he had no rules after that
no no no we know about yeah he was in a
movie called ticker
i swear this is a straight to dvd like
movie where he was in the movie for like
two minutes
and then they kill him but you know back
in the day they used to put rappers in
movies so they could put them on the
artwork so people would ran in and buy
it and i was the one who would run in
and buy it and uh he was he was in it
for two minutes
wasn't diddy and monster ball for two
minutes yeah
he was in prison
by the way
but monsters ball
all-time one of the all-time best nude
scenes
yeah
see i got a problem with uh the white
guy part of it
i got a black problem with something
yeah i get it but i listen i get this
i get it billy
billy bob was handling it billy coat the
coat the head coach with friday night
lights yeah my sling blade billy bob
thornton now [ __ ] sling well yeah yeah
yeah
hey paul hey paul yeah yeah yeah that
was him that was crap bro i just had a
problem with that
and best yeah yeah i can't i can't i was
so into halle berry as a kid billy bob
not sick so that was the second movie
not a sexy man second movie all time
halle berry's breasts were exposed the
first one was swordfish with hugh
jackman and john travolta yes
i had it on vhs and i broke the tape
because i'd pause it on her tits so much
that is savage so you got a little
scratch on it oh yeah it was fun
i was like am i supposed to drink off
this anymore um all right you got two
more movies and then you get the [ __ ]
out of here before we both get canceled
we have a good time yeah we're having
fun
two more movies you got roots both
versions the ti version yeah so that's
all one that's always roots yes boom um
i'm gonna go i'm gonna go
avengers the end in game [ __ ] i mean
that was okay yeah
wait end game is the part one of the one
eight when thanos when they done when
they get cooked right now when they come
back
i don't know i thought it's all the same
kind of right don't they
i'll be confused so one of them [ __ ]
one of the movies okay and i'ma go
apocalypto apocalypto yeah wow there's a
lot of variety there
apocalypto doesn't really have any like
isn't it like in like uh
they're like in the jungle and they're
yeah there's like male gets mayan
yep
mel gibson had he not been such a piece
of [ __ ] one of the best directors
amazing he actually did that jesus film
too as well trust me i'm a [ __ ] i'm
in high school on a date watching the
[ __ ] what's that [ __ ] called the
jesus [ __ ] it's crazy what was it called
passion of the christ christ and i'm an
atheist i don't give a [ __ ] about jesus
but he made me give a [ __ ]
don't say that to me he made me care man
that was crazy right there
i care i'm a god for your man kev
i respect your right to be a god-fearing
man
i fear
uh like my kid's dying or something you
know i have children i fear them getting
sick i understand i fear aliens in the
ocean
okay
have you ever done um psychedelics
you know you didn't have [ __ ]
psychedelics yeah you believe you're
you're getting something there's some
inclination how about this i think more
recently since i've been a little bit
more awakened on the uh
psychedelic tip
maybe i'm not an atheist but i tell you
what i just don't believe in something
i'll tell you this i don't believe in
any man-made religion
i think it's all a way to
control populations control poor people
and it's big business yeah and it's some
of the most corrupt hypocrisy of all
time you know what i'm saying so uh yeah
i guess that's my stance how would you
i'm more of a i don't know
yeah but i've lived in a haunted house
so if i've lived in a haunted house then
that means that there's some other [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] do you do what do you mean
you live in a haunted house lived i
lived in a house that was on how you
know it was on it bro we [ __ ] wake up
in the middle of the night and all the
pots and pans would be out and all the
doors would be open crazy thing i uh
bought a house and renovated renting
shops they had a funeral or a wake okay
you know what i'm saying they showed it
and i was always thinking about stuff
like that so you kind of freak me out
when you say it no it for sure it was uh
our house was over uh a native american
graveyard
so it was pretty [ __ ] wild the house
that uh during this era though my dad
was smoking crack so i could have just
put him in the middle of the night open
up [ __ ]
who knows i don't know reagan got you
too huh sure
[Laughter]
it was never noticeable you know like he
was like very functional you know what i
mean and i think he just had his little
bouts with it but me and my me and my
best friend pops in like the army or
anything no no no no no no no no um but
me and my best friend ramses uh we were
as he's like yes of egypt it's my best
friend in the world his name is ramazeez
yes ramsay rudy king taylor the center
do you like prince of egypt the movie
yeah good cartoon okay keep going here
so uh
we're like thick in master p ghetto dope
era of like my childhood i had a no
limit chain all right
i shoplifted a no limit clothing jersey
from mr rags you know
and i'm going through my dad's drawer
next to his bed i forget what me and
ramsay are you friends i'm from phoenix
phoenix [ __ ] hot place all right
the crack makes it and we found crack
and and my boy rams just pulled it out
and he was like yo this is the ghetto d
[ __ ]
i said damn my dad he's like smoking
crack what the [ __ ] [ __ ] but but but
outside of that and then my mom later on
telling me yeah your dad smoke crack
every once in a while for a little bit
but i never noticed it as a kid it
wasn't like he was like
my dad was like a really hard working
dude he worked like non-stop so he was
probably the most functional crackhead
of all time one of them at least
lots of functional uh drug drug users
yeah anyway well listen man this was fun
likewise bro uh
i'm happy you're putting a new project
that well by the time people watch this
it'll already be out yeah
so go run it up i i think that you're uh
you're one of them ones man and i'm glad
uh that uh i feel like you know people
are starting to really finally give you
your flowers
yeah i can't wait for the tour she's
gonna be crazy is it already locked in
yeah
oh my gosh so it's gonna be insane who's
opening
mm-hmm i'm doing a code thing but
co-headliner it's gonna be crazy another
rapper yeah it's gonna be fire is it you
and black it's gonna be amazing is it
you and black coin
okay if you and black goes behind the
tour that would be crazy i'd buy 20
tickets that would be kind of crazy i'd
bring everything but that would be the
spillage first
yeah that's true yeah marie on there
earth game crew that's that's we could
do apathy
5 to 10k we'll make them
move some major tickets major tickets
jid i'm getting this product oh well
the first time i met you i called you
jid because i i knew people who knew you
that referred to you as jid but you
corrected me pretty harshly did i i was
like we got jid and you were like it's
j.i.d and i was like well [ __ ] me i do
that [ __ ] all the time though it's like
big and biggie
so big and big like it's the same [ __ ]
so
it's whatever what do you prefer
they say something just call me some jed
is acceptable now now that we're you can
now good okay yeah so i'm going to make
sure yeah i do check someone's like oh
you you acting too for me you're like
who's this id who's this goofy radio
[ __ ] hey it's jid bro
my [ __ ] right
[ __ ] anyway there it is appreciate you
bro oh thank you brother boom